Getting a German passport is about to get easier.
And deal citizenship
might soon be possible for more people.
Let's unpack.
Germany's government recently presented a proposal
to reform it citizenship law.
The plan allows for deal citizenship,
simplifies the naturalization process,
and shortens the time required for eligibility
from eight to five years.
And if someone shows a high level of integration,
plus advance your language skills,
citizenship is possible after just three years.
But people dependent on state support,
as well as those convicted of crimes
motivated by anti semitism or racism,
will not be eligible.
The proposed changes in the law could make a defence
for millions of people who live and work in Germany.
It may even help in attracting foreign workers
to fill labour shortages.
So now you know why.